[Music]
my name is Jeffrey I'm a data scientist
at Kickstarter and I'm gonna tell you a
little about how I help to add
automation to our community support team
and how that project helped us all to be
a little more human as many of you
probably know Kickstarter is a
crowdfunding site for raising money for
creative projects there's lots of
creators who come to Kickstarter to
raise money for their documentaries food
trucks board games fidget cubes and
there's lots more backers who come to
make pledges to these projects often in
exchange for a promised future reward so
you give me money so I can record my
country album then I'll send you a copy
of it when it's done in a year that's
how it works so there's the next button
okay okay there's lots of types of
people who use the Kickstarter platform
and there are just as many ways that
things can go wrong for them so when
things do go wrong people can go on our
web site to the Help section type into a
text box with their question and that
will get sent along as an email to our
support team and like many companies
that have products and users Kickstarter
has a dedicated customer support team
which we call the community support team
or the Cs team these are the folks who
answer these support emails from the
users we have nine dedicated in-house Cs
agents and seven remote contractors that
altogether answer answer around 1,500 to
2,000 of these support emails every week
otherwise known as tickets so you know
not a huge scale but still a lot for a
small team and the I think that these
community support employees are the
people they're really the folks who most
understand how our product works and who
our users really are and partially
because of that everybody in our company
participates in something called a
support rotation and that's when you
spend a week learning how to be a
community support agent and you answer a
handful of tickets and it's a great way
to learn about the ins and outs of our
own platform and in your support
rotation you also you can't help it gain
like a deeper deeper empathy
where the actual humans who use
Kickstarter and it's also a great way to
gain stronger empathy for the your
co-workers who actually work on the
community support team full-time which I
think has a lot of value so I signed up
for this support rotation the first week
it was offered and I learned quite a lot
when I was doing it first I learned that
answering support tickets is very hard
and as much as I'd like to think
otherwise and that I realized I was
definitely not an expert at on how
Kickstarter zone products work secondly
and it sounds kind of funny to say but I
learned that our users are real people
as data folks our jobs are to understand
our users through the data that they
generate but really the data points are
only shadows of the humans that create
them and in communicating directly to
these users these people engaging them
in conversation through my support
rotation it served as an important
reminder to me that the people using our
products are much more deep and nuanced
too than any tracking data could ever
hope to capture so the third thing I
learned on my support rotation was how
the support ticketing system works
behind the curtain so when a user writes
a support ticket into a text box on our
website it gets sent to the third-party
community support platform called
Zendesk which probably a lot of people
are familiar with it's pretty powerful
incoming tickets are automatically
linked to metadata about the user who
wrote the ticket such as if they're a
backer or a creator how old their
account is stuff like that that gets all
sent in and then these tickets pile up
in the queues in Zendesk and that's
where our community support agents log
in and they picked them off and write
responses to them pretty standard stuff
that but the agents don't usually write
responses from scratch and this is
something that probably a lot of people
already know about but I didn't and
instead for commonly asked questions
from users our community support agents
just apply a simple tag to the ticket
and that tag generates a pre-written
templated response known as a macro so
in this case like the ticket is about if
Kickstarter has phone support and they
would just apply a tag called phone
support and it would attack
this like pre-written responds
approximate content some of these
responses are customizable others are
self-contained and some of them serve to
get the conversation going and others
serve to resolve issues with finality
so these Zendesk tags can trigger other
things too like rerouting support
tickets to different agents or even
sending off responses automatically
rather than just populating the response
field and the community support team is
in charge of how all this stuff is
configured within Zendesk
and they're very efficient at it they
can like churn through these things
really fast okay yeah oh and all this
data that lives in Zendesk the tickets
the tags the response is it all gets
copied to the Kickstarter database
regularly using a service called five
Tran that we used copy that data okay
and finally on my support rotation I
learned firsthand just about the pain
points and the bottlenecks of the
community support workflow so first of
all like I mentioned the the team is
pretty small and the ticket volume is
high it's high for the for that amount
of people and I learned that I'll do a
lot of the tickets that come in do
require a lot of high touch bespoke
responses many of the other tickets that
come in can be solved with a
straightforward factual pre-written
macro in just a matter of seconds
and so but those act those seconds add
up and so the idea arose that if we
could perhaps automate some of these
easier responses it could help the
community support folks to free up some
valuable energy that they could
otherwise be sent spending on the harder
tickets and all as well as other things
that that team wants a prioritize such
as like rewriting our frequently asked
question pages or like configuring more
things in Deskin I don't know all sorts
of stuff training new employees so ok so
I wanted to try to build a classifier
that could automatically pick a macro
for a ticket
based on the content of the tickets text
just a text classification and I felt
like I was actually in a lucky position
to
to take this project on with a lot of
autonomy so for a for a little bit about
Kickstarter for a fairly well-known
brand which I think Kickstarter is we're
actually pretty small our data team
consists of just six people I'm the one
data scientist there and it's largely
been my job to come up with data
products like these and to figure out
how to collaborate with people to get
them built and I did have space on my
roadmaps for an internal tools project
like this and so I decided to go all in
on this effort and try to help out our
colleagues on the community support team
okay
so now getting robots to do customer
support is not anything we've already
like talked about chatbots at this very
day we've all experienced online help
and chat room support sometimes it works
better than others sometimes it feels
like it's coming from the wrong side of
the uncanny valley and at Kickstarter
it was always important for me and for
the end for this community support team
that we proceed with care and discretion
when heading down this road towards
automation we wanted to make sure that
whatever we built would be done not to
replace the need for human help but
rather to relieve the humans on the
community support team of their most
repetitive sort of unhuman tasks so they
could focus on the more human tasks
common story and from the user
perspective we wanted to make sure that
if we ever ended up sending actually
sending out automated responses that we
would own that own that fact and that
own the fact that the reply was
automated and message it as such just
like hey this is a robot and we think
that you're interested in this
information if it's not if we're wrong
then that's cool so we also decided that
this automation if we built it would
only would only be designed to work on
first touch take tickets meaning that if
a user ever replied back to a robot it
would always get sent to a human so we
don't have to like set our guard rails
pretty modestly and not try to build
something that was going to get us a bad
reputation or something so with all this
in mind I set out to try to build my
little classifier and as a machine
learning classification project it's
like a fun problem and for this
particular context
it was particularly fun because the
training date was built in the text of
the tickets forms my features and
Zendesk macro tags that were used to
respond to those tickets would form the
labels and so I could just tokenize this
ticket text make some simple bags of
words for each ticket run those through
some kind of a classifier and get an
array of probabilities or scores
corresponding to each possible output
label and then perhaps like figure out
how if any of those probabilities were
high enough we could take some action
like automatically sending a response or
something so I started out as simple as
possible I used the tools that I knew
how to use which is r and g LM net to
just build a simple multi-class logistic
regression classifier on a sample of a
few thousand tickets and sort of naively
at my first attempt was I tried to use
all the token for my features I tried to
use all the tokens and two grams that
appeared in in all my tickets which is
like in tens of thousands of features
and for my labels I just wanted to use
all the macro tags that were ever used
to respond to those tickets in my sample
of which there are over a hundred
different ones so this model did not
converge definitely just overflowed in R
whatever whatever happens when our
breaks and so so I you know did the next
thing which is cleaned up my feature set
using standard stuff like stemming
removing stop words removing sparse
terms from my set of my bag of bags of
words and I worked with the CS team to
pare down my training labels but just
figuring out what are the macro tags
that we might actually really want to
automate and in the end and also by
grouping together different sets of
multiple related macro tags and two
parent labels that we could perhaps just
like group into one action and this got
the number of labels down to it like ten
or eight and this model did converge and
had decent accuracy seemed to work with
some sense and so I put it into a shiny
app so I could show it off and try to
get some buy-in and this is a sort of a
simplified version of what that looked
like and in this prototype something I
mean wasn't perfect some of the labels
were easier to sort of hit than others
like when sort of showing it to people
and it definitely didn't cover the huge
a very huge portion of the real-life
continuum of support tickets but it was
enough to get people interested in the
project and so I was able to get
together in a room with some platform
and engineering folks and as well as
some community support folks and my
manager on the data team and we
brainstorm different products that this
prototype could lead to and so my first
naive idea is that like maybe we could
just build something a lot like this
prototype where you get real-time pop-up
help as your help suggestions as you're
typing on the website so for it like as
you're typing your support question you
classify your text in real-time and
surface relevant like help articles or
FAQ links to hopefully answer your
question without you having to submit a
support ticket in the first place and
that's like lots of companies have this
kind of thing and you can definitely buy
this as a service Zendesk I think I
don't have sin disk does real time but
they sell this kind of thing but for us
to build this would require a lot of
product design and front-end development
and we didn't have the resources for
that for this project so it's kind of
like a low-key project so instead for
MVP we just decided to build a
classifier that would bypass any user
facing interface and instead after
classifying the text of a ticket we
would just use Zendesk api to reach back
into Zendesk and apply a tag directly on
the ticket that we classified based on
whatever the predicted classification
was so then those automated tags once
they are applied in Zendesk could then
be configured to trigger different
actions such as auto responding to
tickets or sorting tickets by priority
or routing tickets to different cs
agents or groups and so like I said this
MVP would not have any front-end
components so we could kind of fly under
the radar and building it and best of
all it would keep most of the action
within the Zendesk ecosystem and that
was important to me because the
community support team who sort of owns
that Zendesk ecosystem would be able to
have the ultimate say as to
gets automated and what doesn't and I
think that was important so we decided
to build the thing and we named it sassy
that's a portmanteau of support
classifier and can ask me later about
our classy flashy and trashy there are
there classifiers classes for auto
approving projects flashes for
predicting success and trashley as a
spam classifier okay so yeah so next we
had to just figure out where we were
gonna build this thing in our stack so
my again my first sort of naive thought
was well why don't we just use the shiny
app that I already built but but you
know I looked online to see if shiny was
recommended for you set production scale
and I'd found like mixed reviews and
also none of the engineering people that
we work with like know anything about
shiny so we decided that was maybe not
the way right way to go I don't know if
shiny is used for production but maybe
maybe it is maybe it isn't I don't know
but we didn't go for that so the next
thought was maybe we could just bolt
Sassie onto our already monolithic
kickstarter rails app we already have
one text classifier that lives in the
rails app it's a logistic regression
classifier pretty simple
um so we could reuse a lot of that code
but being a logistic regression going
that route we would probably be limiting
ourselves to using logistic regression
for that with the model inside sassy
would be and I was a bit wary of that
because like that's I wanted to try out
other models that might be able to have
nonlinear stuff so also the engineering
team at this point was making a big push
to get away from this monolithic
architecture more towards microservices
so adding stuff to the monolith was not
something they were super keen on doing
either so the better option was to just
let sassy be its own micro service and
it was a great candidate for being a
micro service it was brand new so no
that wouldn't wouldn't have to refactor
existing code I mean maybe that's a good
or bad I don't know but to me it was
good and it's a pretty autonomous so it
doesn't need to really interact with any
other resources outside of itself to be
able to work so we had a winner and
sassy was greenlit and we all aligned
our roadmaps
so the platform folks would help to
build the services plumbing other
engineering folks would help to hook the
Kickstarter rails app up to this service
to call in to it and then apply the
responses from the service into the
Zendesk API the data person me would
train the model and figure out how to
insert it in the codebase of that
service and most importantly the
community support team was on board and
they put goals on their timeline to be
able to automatically prioritize reroute
and auto reply to some tickets by the
end of the year this is like I guess a
year and a half ago um yeah so the the
Kickstarter engineering team had decided
that all of our new micro services would
be written in Java they surveyed a few
different languages and decided that was
the best one for our needs and so that's
what we decided that we would use to
build Sasi so for me that means that
meant that I had to figure out how to
train them all than our but then because
that's that's what I'm know how to use
and then deploy it in Java and I also
had to learn some Java which I was
actually excited to do because I don't
know I done C++ in my previous job in
those languages are kind of similar so
that was actually exciting to get to
Lince with me but I didn't know anything
about how to do machine learning in Java
or how'd it go from there to there and I
think this challenge of figuring out how
to productionize your prototypes is
something well something I've run up
against several times probably other
people have too and I mean with some
classifiers like logistic regression the
model logic is simple enough that you
can encapsulate it just as a list of
coefficients so it's not that hard to
just like copy those coefficients from
where you chained the thing in to the
thing where you serve the thing and and
then you have your model running on
production but more complicated models
like tree based models or neural
networks like are not so easy to just
like pour it by hand and there are lots
of solutions for this but it's still the
problem that was required some thought
but I was in luck because for this
specific case of going from are into
Java there is a popular product
available that's h2o so it's an
open-source machine learning platform a
lot of people have probably heard of it
runs on the JVM
it exploits a lot of nice things there
does a lot of parallel processing for
loading modeling data fast can scale it
also has nice interface interfaces for
your favorite machine learning training
languages like our Python Scala and it
also has a web GUI yeah so we decided to
try out h2o it's it worked for us
because it also has a lot of different
types of classification models that it
can train from neighed bayes classifiers
to deep learning models this is the one
that we settled on which was a tree
based model a gradient boosting machine
and yeah so that's actually just that
that's the command for training the
thing on our with a bunch of hyper it
parameters that we spent a lot of time
spend a lot of time trying to figure out
how to how to optimize so ok so once you
train your h2o model which could take
minutes or hours depending on your
machine and your data size and
cross-validation size and all that stuff
then you have it sitting there in memory
and R has just this file called model
and so how do you ship this model out to
your java service in order to deploy it
well and h2o which you can do is you
export the model as what's called a POJO
and that's just a acronym it means plain
old Java object and POJO looks something
like this it's that's the poggio for
sassy it's just a bunch of
auto-generated code you can't really see
because it clips but it's about five
hundred sixty thousand lines of code but
it includes all of the all of the logic
of this tree base model you can kind of
see this like a lots of distance
statements and the thing that's nice
about it is it exports all of that logic
as a Java class using primitive Java
data types and containers so you can
just like plug it right into your to
your Java project and it'll work so it
can be it can be massive this one is
pretty massive but it does it worked
fine and so once you export your POJO
file then you just bring it over to your
java project and you copy it in deploy
it and it can just work and then you
have a classifier model that was trained
in
our anout serving a request on
production in Java so great but I don't
want to make it sound like that but that
was easy for me I mean maybe it's easy
to do but for me it was actually took a
long time just to figure out how that
whole setup worked and so I mean I spend
a lot of time just figuring out all the
different parts of this workflow such as
like just learning what the different
classifier models do this is one of my
first attempts at like learning trying
out a bunch of different classifier
models and then learning about all their
hyper parameters and reading about with
what the high parameter to just do and
seeing how you know changing those hyper
parameters affect the performance of our
particular use case I spend a lot of
time trying to get my text tokenization
set up right and that was kind of a like
a blunder of poor programming style on
my part but I built a tokenizer in our
that I wrote a tokenizer in our that
would you know clean that clean the raw
text of a support ticket tokenize it and
all that stuff but then I realized that
I had to rewrite all of those all that
code in Java to be able to tokenize
incoming tickets and so wound up having
like the same code duplicated in two
different places which gets a little
weird when you're trying to like use
sort of third-party steamers and stuff
so that was kind of like a it was just
something that I painted myself into a
corner and I had to manage that so I
took a little while I also had to spend
a lot of time figuring out that
exporting a POJO file is a thing that
people do and actually spend a lot of
time with the on the phone with the
patient sales reps at h2o trying to ask
them how do I train a model in Java and
they're like what you mean you export
the thing eventually I went to H to a
conference to just ask the people I got
how do you use this thing and then they
told me used to poach it so and then I
spent had to spend a long time figure
out how the poacher actually works so I
could plug it into the service and and
finally this is a problem where I spent
a lot of time figuring out with what our
success metrics should be for this type
of a model and so you know the quality
the the metric that you choose to
measure the success of your model like I
think depends a lot on the expected
business use of the model it's
so for instance if we're trying to build
a classifier that's going to auto
respond to tickets we probably want to
optimize for something like precision so
we maybe are okay with the idea of not
Auto responding to many tickets we just
want to make sure that when we do auto
respond we get it right but if instead
we're doing like pop-up help like where
we maybe offer like three or four
possible help articles as you're typing
then that's that
I forget what someone else called it but
it's like you would only mean your your
your answer to be precise within maybe
the top three or four most probable
labels on the other hand if you're
trying to optimize for like reducing the
workload of your community support team
then maybe you're trying to optimize put
more weight on like the recall side of
things you want to make sure you
classify take action on as many tickets
as possible and it's okay if you get a
few of them wrong so we kind of didn't
really know what a use case was we kind
of wanted to actually serve a lot of
those different use cases so you try to
optimize all those things at once by you
know some of these you can which you can
do with those what is it
area under the curve or f1 measure f1
half-measure depending on how you weigh
things so anyway but despite all of
those challenges and time-consuming
things and after mini pull requests last
December we finally did ship this thing
called sassy and saw the first automated
tags appearing in Zendesk it was great
so now if you go to Kickstarter and you
submit a support ticket it'll still get
sent over to Zendesk but it'll also get
sent into our little sassy service where
it'll get tokenized and run through our
GBM classifier model and that will
return back to our app a list of labels
and probabilities and then there's some
logic and thresholds in the app that
will then decide whether it needs to if
any of those probabilities are high
enough then it can reach into Zendesk
through its api find the ticket that it
was looking at and apply the the
appropriate tag to that ticket and then
actions can be set up to be triggered by
that tag within Zendesk
okay so this MVP is it's viable it's but
still modest sassy only applies tags to
about 10% of incoming tickets of those
10% the accuracy of which tags it
applies it is around 90% not great not
bad that's based on manual quality
assessments we've done after after we
deployed it tags that trigger auto
responses tend to be a lot more accurate
because that's we wouldn't use them as
auto responses if they weren't then tags
to do other things and there's a lot of
things that we could do to improve this
this this thing like finding maybe a
better model that could have more than
just like well I guess this one
represents this represents the was this
average time for first response for a
different Sasi etags
right now there's only 7 different
different tags that Sasi could apply so
we could maybe train a different model
that could apply like 70 tags instead of
7 but I don't know how to do that yet so
is what we're working with but you can
see that you know the response time for
things that were says but were tagged by
Sasi went down and the one thing that we
did Auto responses for which is people
having issues uploading videos and stuff
first the response time went way down
which is oh we would have hoped but you
know for all the things we could do to
improve this MVP it's it's we're
equipped and the more importantly the
community support team is equipped to
iterate on what we already have and so
kind of what I mean by that is that so
as data scientists and engineers we're
all builders and we build things in
service of our users whether those are
external users such as Kickstarter
creators and backers or in the case of
internal tools like this or users maybe
our own coworkers and so part of
building things in service of others is
in understanding the needs of those
users through things like just user
research or doing things like support
rotations and just taking an attitude of
empathy to everything you do and and in
the case of internal tools I think that
part of serving others is in building
ourselves out of the equation so meaning
we want to
things in such a way that we empower our
colleagues to own and maintain their own
tools themselves so I wanted to do this
for a sassy and I mentioned before that
Kickstarter's ecosystem with in Zendesk
is owned and operated by the community
support team
I wanted Sasi to be the same way so like
I kind of alluded to earlier a major
part of Sassy's functionality is the
configuration of its training labels
remember there's hundreds of macros the
the CS team uses but there's only about
seven or eight sassy labels in a little
model so macros are grouped into parent
labels for training and these parent
labels are what get supplied as tags in
Zendesk so we knew from the beginning
that these labels would not be set in
stone and we need to regularly update
and change them as we tested and
iterated on this model in the wild and
as the actual content of support tickets
change over time and as the needs of our
Community Support Team change over time
as well so I set it up so that the macro
groupings live in a config file and that
config files essentially owned by the
community support team so there it is
and the community support people that I
worked with have github access and they
can modify the bat config file and the
the groupings of these macros labelings
themselves with a request and so then
they pretty much own the entire
lifecycle of sassy so that's a that's
NOAA's pull request to change the labels
and that's me saying it looks great yeah
so the CS team they I mean they
configure with in Zendesk they configure
which actions are triggered by the tags
that sassy produces they've built
dashboards in looker to monitor Sassy's
behavior over time they perform manual
quality assessments of the labels that
sassy does apply to just see how they do
in real life and then then like shown
here they adjust the training label
config file in response to these quality
assessments submit those changes and get
up through PR then then the only part
where I come in is and approving the PR
and then I execute the training script
and the deployment script and then it's
back to in their hands so the life's
like this life cycle can continue and it
pretty much is owned by them furthermore
like when presenting about this at all
hands like the
Sport team does the presenting I'm just
in the background to answer technical
questions they've organized talk so
though the company is to talk about the
question of automating support and again
if I participate I'm just there to help
out if people have like questions about
the stack but it's their show and and
that's I love that and the most cool
thing about this whole process to me is
that the community support folks that I
worked with have really developed an
intuition for the strengths and limits
of the machine learning model that we
use and they have a much more into
better intuition of how I might perform
differently on different training label
configurations as different types of
data it's pretty cool so we set out to
build a robot to help out humans and we
try to do it with an attitude of empathy
curiosity and collaboration and the
support rotation that I participated in
was an exercise designed in part for us
to gain empathy for our users and our
colleagues and the Sassi project sought
to bring in automation as a tool so that
our community support humans could spend
more time being human and so we built
sassy with the intention for empowering
that community support team both in how
the tool functions and how its
maintained and owned by that team and
also I think working on this project has
made me realize that scrappy teams can
build cool things and our team is small
and none of us was really an expert in
the field of automation but we worked
with what we had and we built something
cool to better serve our users and our
friends and that feels good thank you
oh I think there's a question over there
hey so I think early on you're kind of
talking about how you trained the model
[Music]
so do the tickets is there only kind of
like one tag per ticket is that why you
could is yeah great price opposed to a
ticket being multiple okay yeah for the
most part there's one mostly one tag
particular but there definitely are some
overlaps there are situations where for
whatever reason maybe it's like because
it's a back and forth thread or maybe
just maybe because of things I don't
understand how Zendesk works like there
would be situations or multiple tags
would be applied or maybe some tags
don't correspond to a macro but they get
applied for other reasons and so they're
you know I did my best effort to try to
like find individually tagged tickets
but there's definitely some fuzziness
there so that's another thing we're
improving this in the future would be
just getting the training data a little
bit more like precise so I'm just
curious if you have an opinion on if if
there are tickets with multiple tags
because the ticket could be partly about
passwords and partly about a video and
like do you know of ways that you can
kind of train a model based on more than
one kind of label yeah I mean I off the
top of my head I mentioned you could
just like include the mother each
example twice just waiting with
different labels and then perhaps the
model could learn that the text signals
that correspond to the one label could
also correspond to the other label but I
don't know I don't know how that would
actually perform but that seems like
maybe where I would go with that cool
[Music]